- Le prochain premier ministre
du Canada : Pierre Poilievre.
- Les observateurs anticipaient
ce résultat depuis quelques
confirmé de façon écrasante.
- Le tememememememememememememex
gouvernement qui vous coûte plus
avec un nouveau gouvernement qui
vous place en premier.
- Pierre Poilievre octctctctctcu
premun résultat sans
équivoque.
- C'est un nombre magique, c'est
l'unité pour nous. Il n'y a
aucune ambiguïté. Avec 68 %
comme ça, le message est clair.
- Le succès d'une campagne au
ton souvent dur, aux
déclarations parfois
Aujourd'hui, le gagnant veut
tourner la pag I Il lance un
appel à l'unité des troupes.
- Les attaqu, , , , , , , , , ,a
travailler ensemble et puis avec
unbjbjectif commun, c'est de
remplacer et de former le
prochain gouvernement.ururururut
un retour en politique fédérale,
esest une défaite crève-coeur,
lui qui mettait à l'avant-plan
un programme plus centriste.afat
que sa présence n'a pas été
vaine.IlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIt
été mises de l'avant et ses
ididées-là peuvent servir pour
l'éventuel chef. Il faut garder
leadership, c'est également un
laboratoire d'idées et que les
choses peuvent évoluer.
- Le nouveau chef peut-il les
différentes factions? Ce sera
son pr c c c c c c c c c c c c i
pourrait déterminer la suite
ososes pour certains déput
- Il y a la politique, mais il y
a autre chose après la politique
les mains attachées, je me sens
libre.
- Il est bien là le défi de
Pierre Poilievre, convaincre ses
députés qu'ils ont une place
certaines des positions
tranchées qu'icées
pendant la course, au risque de
s'aliéner ceux qui l'ont élu.
Ici Daniel Thibault, Radio-
Cana